hi there hi christina how are you i am
well thank you for talking to me about
this i loved this so much i thank you i
had the my little pony toys as a kid
i love that they're still around because
it makes me feel like i made good toy
choices
i'm curious when did you become familiar
with them did you just always sort of
have them around always i think it's
just one of those things that's such an
iconic part of everyone's childhood
i always remember knowing about my
little pony and having my little pony
and me and my sister um just brushing
their their hair remember that's so
vividly and of course the theme song
when the opportunity to be a part of
this came your way what was your
reaction then i mean was it like just oh
my god sign me up yes it was such an
easy yes you know it's such a beautiful
and magical world and
something that so many people have loved
for so many years and the cast is just
incredible i mean actors that i've
admired
my whole life and then other female
actresses who are just amazing and
um
it's so cool that all of our heroines
all of our pony heroes are females it's
really amazing
and yeah it was it's been such a
pleasure and such an honor to be a part
of this
when you read the script how easy was it
to imagine what the world would look
like and how did actually getting to see
it in the finished film compared to what
you thought it would be i think the
world was so much bigger and so much
more magical than what we imagined and
that's so beautiful that's i guess
that's the power of
animation the power of my little pony
and
the way that animation works and you
only kind of get to see the pieces that
you're in so it was really special to
kind of watch the movie as a fan and see
so many things that i hadn't actually
seen and it was um it's just
such a beautiful world with so many
important messages
this really is such a cute and sweet
story
is the script that you first read
essentially the final film or did it
change and evolve along the way at all
it's very close i mean i think you know
animations take years and years to
develop so that this had been in the
process for a long time before we even
as cass joined on
um but i was pretty impressed that the
final script was very pretty very true
to the original script i mean there are
certain things that
are improvised in the moment and certain
things that maybe i said that weren't in
the script that made it to the movie but
all in all it was pretty close to the
original
a lot of actors talk about not being
able to watch their own performances
are you someone who normally doesn't
like watching yourself and does it make
it any easier when it's an animated
project and it's just your voice
bringing the character definitely makes
it easier when it's an animated project
for sure but you know i think a lot of
actors and myself included were our own
worst critics which can be a really
beautiful thing because it pushes you to
try and and work harder and to challenge
yourself more and to push yourself
beyond your limits but um it can also be
an achilles heel i think that's why it
makes it hard to see yourselves on
camera but it's um kind of making that
conscious decision in your brain to
separate yourself from the character
that you're playing and knowing that
what you see on camera isn't sophia but
it's you know whatever character i'm
stepping into and sometimes it's a hard
thing to do
the story is less based in a fantasy
world and more feels like it's in a
current world that's very much
identifiable to kids today
what did you find yourself most
identifying with when it comes to this
story
so many things i mean to me that the
most powerful and most important crucial
message of my little pony is like you
said that despite this taking place in
the magical world of equestria
the heart of the story is so real and so
important and so timely it's the story
of the power i guess the greatest magic
in the world which is the power of love
and the power of inclusivity and the
power of unity
um
in a world that has been kind of
torn apart by hatred and division
these ponies who are
these kids
who in the eyes of the world are these
tiny voices
can change the world can change their
great big world by making that fearless
choice of choosing love despite the
world the forces of the world trying to
keep them apart and that's exactly
what's happening in our world today and
our young generation
is the trailblazing generation that's
kind of leading the way in the path to
love what did you love about princess
pet petals aside from just having a
fabulous name like that what did you
most enjoy about getting to
voice her and to find her voice i love
her confidence and she's just so
beautifully
um bravely herself and i also love that
she loves music so much because you know
pip and i have that in common
um and i loved her energy and her spirit
each of her ponies are kind of so
uniquely themselves and that's so
beautiful such a beautiful thing to
celebrate but
pip is special she's definitely a force
at what point did you get to see what
she would look like and did seeing her
affect how you voiced her in any way i
saw a drawing of her when um the project
was offered to me
and in the most beautiful way and she
just kind of jumped off the screen
and um but it was pretty magical to see
her animated and of course seeing her
and how they had envisioned her helped
in in my performance and kind of the
heart that i put into pip
how would you say you're most like pip
and is there a quality of hers that you
wish you had
um me and paper both lovers of music um
and pip is devoted to her pipsqueaks
which are her fans and
um i i'm also so wholeheartedly devoted
and grateful to those that i'm lucky
enough to to be on this journey with my
fans i think we're different in that i
really try to work hard to live in the
present and not to be consumed by our
cell phones while pip i think is
learning the difficult lesson that a lot
of kids these days are learning and that
is that it's so easy to get consumed by
the world of social media and to live
life through a lens rather than being
present in the moment and um pip learns
that in our film
i saw the video of you opening and
playing with your toy for your character
and her whole palace
even though you're voicing a pony do you
still feel a sense of ownership of the
character does she feel like she's a
representation of you
it's interesting i guess there's a piece
of ourselves and all the characters that
we play we leave a little piece of our
heart behind so yeah absolutely it's
pretty surreal when you see the toy um
and it's kind of an out-of-body
experience i think that that's you know
that's the heart that you put into the
character that's your voice
um so that that will never not be
surreal for sure
how did this voice process work did you
ever get to work with any of your
co-stars were you alone the entire time
we're all alone it was also during covid
so it was extra alone and extra careful
even our directors were in different
parts of the world and they were all
there via zoom
um so it's definitely a very different
experience voiceover tends to be quite
different than live action but it made
it i guess extra special when you watch
the finished product because there's so
much that you haven't seen
and voices that you hadn't heard and
songs that you hadn't heard so it's uh
it was beautiful to watch it all back as
a fan
yeah as a performer how strange is it to
work with directors remotely in that way
you know it's something that takes
getting used to but it works especially
for an animated project like this it's
kind of incredible how we can
still make art in the middle of all of
this
what do you enjoy about the relationship
between pip and zip and getting to see
that dynamic that they share and the
dynamic they share with their mother
pip and zip and the royal family has um
i think an incredibly relatable dynamic
you know pip
is this force she's a pop princess and
she takes her role of princess really
seriously and the responsibilities that
come with it in the expectations
well zip really resents royalty and
really resents the expectations that
come with being a princess and so
like a lot of sisterhood relationships
that start in the beginning there's
friction
because pip just wants to be loved and
accepted by her sister and her older
sister's kind of dismissive of her but
when they embark on this really
beautiful journey their lives change
forever and their friendship changes
forever and they become best friends and
i think they see each other
they see their sparkles for who they are
and they accept it and they embrace it
and that is so beautiful and
you know my sister is my best friend and
i know that so many girls out there feel
the same and there's nothing more
special than that relationship
blowing up such a great song what was
your reaction the first time you heard
the song what was it like to not your
own i just thought it was such a
cool song
and that was the goal all along you know
ron fair who is an icon in the industry
is responsible for some of the greatest
careers for instance christina aguilera
just to name one
he um calls us about a year and a half
ago with the idea of
writing an amazing pop record for pip to
be the closing credit song of the movie
and he wanted to bring on a writer named
jenna andrews who's a force right now in
the business she wrote two of the
biggest songs of the year with bts
and um it was all during covet so i
think he was in nashville jenna was in
new york i was in la and we'll kind of
work together and when they sent me
growing up um it was just pretty
immediate and i also loved that the song
was not only a pop record but it had so
much soul to it and r b which i really
relate to
and um
it's just beautiful to be able to voice
a record that's about finding your inner
glow and letting it shine for the world
to see
it's hard to know how to handle fame
until you're in the spotlight
what does most surprise you about
yourself having had the spotlight shown
on you for a bit now have you learned
anything about your own strengths that
you didn't realize
it is um a completely different world
once you enter the world of
of fame um what i learned about myself
is
i think that
what um fame does and what this world
does is i think it just kind of
heightens everything a bit more and so
it just makes
values and family and having people
around you who just truly care about you
and that you care about them just that
much more important um so i think to me
i got even closer to my family even
closer to my sister
and um closer to the values and morals
that i was raised with
as a performer how do you find your own
inner confidence are there friends or
family in your life that give you a pep
talk when you need it do you give
yourself a pep talk when you need it
it's funny because i think that i was
having this conversation with my co-star
recently about how as performers i think
you know
you have to have a certain level of
confidence right to be brave enough to
be in front of a camera and bare your
soul or to go in front of a stage and
sing in front of thousands but at the
same time
performers um can be so critical of
themselves and and we can tend to doubt
whether we we can do things all the time
but it's only because we want to be
better better and grow
um but i think that confidence has to
come from within no matter what anyone
tells you if you don't believe it
yourself
nothing that anyone says can convince
you otherwise and um
like anyone else in the world i think
confidence comes in waves but
you really just have to wholeheartedly
believe in yourself because that's kind
of the fire that
lights everything that you do
you're currently working on purple
hearts which i i think is so cool that
you're also a co-writer on that
executive producer you're performing the
soundtrack you're wearing many hats on
that project
how did that happen what was it about
that that you felt connected enough to
that you wanted to become so involved
with it thank you so much um i actually
i just drove in this morning i had two
concerts this weekend um while filming
the movie and we were capturing content
for the movie so it has been
the most extraordinary we've been
shooting for three weeks and i don't
ever want it to end um i've been
developing this project with my director
liz allen and with her partners at alloy
and now netflix for four years now and
i'm just forever grateful to liz who
believed in me when we were shooting
perfectionists and wanted to bring this
to life with me as a producer with her
and for me to have a voice in developing
cassie and and the world of purple
hearts
what drew me to the story the most was
the message
and when when i first read the title i
asked liz if purple hearts meant it was
the blending of a red and blue heart
and she giggled and she said
i hadn't thought of it that way but
that's exactly what our story is and you
know we live in a country that is so
incredibly divided right now red versus
blue and um
[Music]
this story is about
choosing not to see color and choosing
love above all things and how a red
heart and blue heart can come together
and choose love and it can change the
world in the most beautiful way
and um i came on as a writer as well for
the music and
um i was able to write with i'm not sure
if i can say who it is quite yet but
my co-writer on this project is one of
the greatest writers of our generation
i'm so grateful to work with him and
we really put our hearts into bringing
cassie's music to life and it's just
been um
the most challenging role of my life and
the most rewarding one so far as well
sounds really exciting yeah thank you
well you've had a successful acting and
singing career you're branching out into
being a writer and producer you're a
brand ambassador for revlon you're a
role model for a lot of young people
can you appreciate the success that
you've already achieved does that
directly fuel a drive to push you even
further
it it
just hearing you say everything i have
to pinch myself and take a step back
because it doesn't it doesn't feel real
and just this weekend when i was looking
out into the crowd and
hearing people sing my songs back or a
couple of them were holding my little
ponies or a couple of them were dressed
as evie or a couple of them were showing
me the revlon lipsticks
um is
unreal and i'm just so lucky because i
get to do what i love every single day
and
it doesn't feel like work um
i just feel like the luckiest girl in
the world and what fuels me the most is
those young men and women and however
they identify the fact that they
um connect to me and i can connect them
in a way is the most special thing in
the world and every story that i tell i
tell for them and i just
long to keep doing it
it definitely seems like a huge
responsibility but at the same time a
lot of fun
that's exactly what it is it is a huge
responsibility but i don't think i would
i know that i wouldn't have it any other
way
well i appreciate you talking to me
about this the movie is just so adorable
it had i put a smile on my face the
entire time i watched it that's all that
matters
it was so fun and the music is just
fantastic so thank you thank you so much
thank you for your time
thank you